hallo leute ich will eure mal wandern
bekommen zu einem neuen video heute
retten wir kellys erdbeer vanille
marshmallow kuchen wer sich mit kellys
backkünste auskennt weiß dass sie in der
küche ein wenig struggled wenn es um
gebäck und backwaren gehen wo ich sagen
muss dass die mittlerweile schon ganz
schön gut kochen können und ich als ihre
beste freundin muss dann natürlich
einschreiten und zeigen dass ich es
besser kann kelly
wenn ich zeigen will dass ich was besser
kann also trigger warnung für dich hier
aber du bietest mir halt tun konnte
and that's what friends are for die
statue mit dem video in dem sie sagt
dass sie das rezept zwei schnauze macht
einen kuchen zu backen und dann blendet
sie ein rezept für rührteig 1
und ich werde das verwenden wir
vertrauen jetzt einfach mal an dieser
stelle und nehmen 275 g weiche butter 75
gramm gabriel eine prise seien 150 gramm
mehl und ein gehäufter teelöffel
backpulver das ist der teig 24 cm ja es
wird ja auch ein kleiner kuchen
dann zeigt sie uns tortenguss und bevor
sie uns ihre restlichen zutaten zeigt
sie an die zubereitung und das machen
wir jetzt auch zwei eier
ich mach das mal alles ein augenmaß
der rest von diesen backpulver
doppelfolge starten können muss unsere
butterweich werden
margarine köstliche bio margarine wir
haben 250 gramm das heißt wir müssen es
in das sind 75 gramm habe ich richtig
berechnet 80 gramm unsere margarine wird
jetzt einfach schneller wenn wir sie
klein schneiden und jetzt müssen wir
warten ein paar sekunden später verwies
weich was kelly nicht weiß ist dass es
besser ist wenn man die eier trend erst
mal nur das eigelb verwendet und zudem
ein gelb kommt jetzt unser zucker von
unsere fast weiche butter und das
schlagen wir auch
durch das extrem lange aufschlagen
bekommt man so eine mutige masse und die
butter wird auch richtig kennen süße
butter mit schaden kanns net die
backpulver mischung geben jetzt langsam
hinzu genauso wie einen schluck welt
das ist ein ganz schön fester teil aber
jetzt auch sehr schön weil er sehr
witzig ist was da jetzt noch fehlt auf
geschlagenes eiweiß nachdem harry potter
torten video auf jeden fall wie man
eiweiß aufschlägt
einzig was wir zum aufschlagen brauchen
ist eine prise salz und dann die scheiße
aufschlagen ist euer eiweiß steif macht
den test
so steigt das jetzt nicht mehr raus
kriegt wenn eigelb und eiweiß sich
wiedergefunden haben rührt man sie
vorsichtig und einander dass sie sich
wieder vereinen durch diese vereinigung
erlangen sie eine flüssigkeit die
unübertrefflich ist perfekt die
konsistenz ist glaube ich ganz gut
kelly nennt ihnen den auflauf kuchen
weil sie es in eine auflaufform kann ich
dachte mir da so das schwerst so
zuschneiden nehmen wir grill aluschalen
dann machen wir zwei schichten und dann
können wir sie am ende übereinander
stapeln ich weiß nicht wie wichtig das
ist aber man kann sich so ein bisschen
einfetten und ich benutze die alu sein
weil ich die ja ich hier noch rum liegen
haben das praktisch ist unser a new form
gefettet kann auch der teig reitet nur
die hälfte
so viel muss reichen
mal geht noch ein bisschen auf hoffe er
geht noch ein bisschen aussieht sehr
flüssig aus ist ein gutes zeichen der
roten nummer 1 an boden nummer 2 und die
komm jetzt 175 grad umluft in den ofen
ich denke sie sind in 15 minuten fertig
gebacken sind jetzt ziemlich klein bis
gleich ins pedal anteil und mein gott
was schief
[Musik]
die sind einfach perfekt geworden jetzt
sind sie auch abgekühlt und wir können
weiter machen
die stadt ihre restlichen zutaten angabe
und so länger ich die restlichen zutaten
einfach an starke umso mehr weiß ich
dann mit was ich weitermachen soll
marshmallows kuchen glasur wandeln und
vanillepudding feste vanillepudding
creme habe mich natürlich entschieden
wie selbst gemacht kein bock hat braucht
für vanille pudding muss mein rezept
vanille extrakt milch butter zucker
eigelb und speisestärke und so wenn
vanillepudding zubereiteten halben liter
milch jeder in den topf geben und
[Musik]
vanille oder wandel extrakt rein macht
das muss jetzt aufkochen und die milch
kocht nehmen wir unser eigen was wir aus
einer harry potter torte doch übrig
haben
teil drei mal klar ist ganz normaler
alltag und da kommt ein bisschen puder
zu grau und dann wird gerührt 30 farben
speisestärke rein und ich mag den song
schuss von der armen milch weil die
milch kocht jetzt einrühren
das ist anstrengend als mit sport und so
einfach geht das nicht so schnell super
einfach klasse dass wir das muss jetzt
in der schüssel und abkühlen zum google
selbst gemacht hat pudding dagegen okay
wir haben uns unseren kuchen wurde ich
würde sagen wir machen auch eine
vanillecreme in der mitte das ist eine
gute idee so legen wir los
das wird unser präsentiert helga kann
man die jetzt wieder zum besten
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass dieser
gucken so aufwendig ist aber anscheinend
ist er so aufwendig lasst uns loslegen
so hier unsere zwei schichten der auch
irgendwie dass sie mehr aus wien
roth ich werde ein bisschen die decke
abschneiden weil ich doch fest beworben
nur so an kratzen würde mir das gerade
ist und wir probieren können
und ja er werde jetzt mit
erdbeermarmelade samt feine eine
geschichte streicht harry hatte trat
keine füllung aber ich finde so eine
füllung kann macht immer noch was
nun brauchen wir unsern noch warmen
vanillepudding muss sie noch warm sein
aber ich habe keine geduld mehr taufe
der wird richtig fest kommt jetzt
einfach so um drauf und dann wird unser
brot zugemacht
gib dich kelly das ist ein super rezept
und weil das so gut hält die summen
gemalten seiten zu machen sind unsere
schnitte und die kommt in kühlschrank
ist noch lange nicht das ende
wir müssen jetzt die mandeln an denn
gerüstete mandelsplitter schmecken
besser als nicht gerüstet mann der
später in die karre die wenn jetzt an
gerüstet und ich habe jetzt nur richtig
guten plan wird gleich auch noch die
marshmallows schmelzen werden wir die
marshmallows um diesen herum machen
darauf werden wir die gerösteten mandeln
dann kommen schokolade und dann kommen
bisschen cool
dann kommen die habe ich glaube so der
planer
wow das ist mein blick auf die fahnen
[Musik]
und nun brauche ich ein bisschen fett
und wie marshmallow kelly hat sion top
drauf gelegt ich will aber er so einen
luft krähen zeugen die dann an den rand
kambodscha wird geschmolzen und dann
bogen die maßnahme prahlen dass wir dem
top schnaufen so dass es unter
marshmallow creme moody's hochkochen
tollen hier sind ja gucken wir mal was
über zu stellen muss er bearbeitet
werden so lange sie noch heiß es das
kommt jetzt gibt es für das sage ich
hier mache auch diese marshmallow kleben
ist unsere gerösteten mandeln der beste
klebstoff denn es gibt dafür also bis
jetzt gut aus wenn ich das mal so sagen
da zur küche schmecken
ihr wart doch unser glas glas klausur um
das sieht gut aus
ja mich entschieden auf den tortenguss
zu 40 aber probieren
[Musik]
die weihnachten einfache wir machen die
glasur drauf und während sie noch
flüssig ist kommen die erdbeeren drauf
im moment of truth
[Musik]
dann starten wir die erdbeeren liebevoll
gewesen und schon runter mensch toll
dass schuldig so die restliche klausur
machen jetzt mal den rand und die noch
zu retten wir haben unseren kuchen
was soll ich sagen es ist einfach
unfassbar grauenvoll von ende musste er
gut schmecken und das ding mal
anschneiden
am ende das stück sind gar nicht mal so
scheiße aus es schmeckt wirklich war es
grauenvoll nicht mehr kellys grube
gerettet gerettet
[Musik]
kraft die mandeln schmecken gott die
mandeln sind richtig lecker und ich habe
mich gewundert warum mittels erinnert
das sind gebrannte mandeln assist und
lag nur ihr da kuchen eine komische
kombination aus illegal haben wir gerne
in die kommentare was ich noch retten
soll
wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
eine küche wissen schlachtfeld bis dahin
steht sport machen